and organization page so I'll have
badness okay so let's begin good morning
everyone and welcome to bioinformatics
for precision medicine this program will
highlight biomedical applications of big
data bioinformatics in the context of
major diseases like cancer and chronic
infection for those joining us for the
first time my name is Ilya Brodsky I am
the co-founder and CEO of pine biotech
our vision is to enhance human health
and well-being by enabling biological
research and discovery with relevant
data solutions and support our mission
is to simplify bioinformatics and
Advanced Research through our modular
and intuitive multi onyx analysis
platform powered by human experience and
artificial intelligence we offer
training research support and big data
analytics tools designed for research
and biomedical discovery our mission is
to continue to support cutting-edge
research and help solve big data
challenges by developing innovative
solutions that are easy to use and
provide training to use them effectively
and arrive at sound and reproducible
results I am honoured to have been
working at Pine biotech with many others
many of our team members have much more
experience in this area than I including
Pine biotech co-founders dr. Alfred
caliber who comes from a medical
background with expertise in oncology
immunology and biochemistry of
inflammation
he has a long-standing recognition for
his generous support of many
international projects and research
activities one of these projects is the
establishment of the Talbert
bioinformatics Research Center at
University of Haifa dr. Lena Brodsky is
the director of the tower by informatics
Research Center and is an expert in
bioinformatics
and biostatistics he has numerous
publications on bioinformatics and over
the course of his career has developed
multiple novel algorithmic approaches
for biomedical data analysis these have
been widely used in basic and
translational research and biotechnology
pharmaceutical R&D AG
culture and biomedical research what we
will discuss today is also the result of
hard work by some of the people
mentioned here on the left
Julia Panov who is an expert by
informatician F and has helped prepare
many of the materials that we will use
in this course
I beat ETF ski who is a computer
scientist and leads the development of
the tea balloon for platform that we
will utilize Boheme Mazumdar who is in
charge of business development for Pine
biotech internationally Josh from
McKenna who maintains the educational
web portal we will leverage and beeps of
Biswas are an online community manager
and support specialist why I'm sure many
of you had already had the chance to
interact with the program is designed to
highlight the role of big data bio and
chemo informatics these are shaping
modern biomedical innovation where
molecular data is used for precision
diagnostics big data integration and
machine learning or transforming
personalization of treatment selection
and innovative algorithms that allow for
unprecedented capabilities with drug
discovery design of large molecules and
drug repurposing and repositioning
molecular data is routinely used in
medicine for patient stratification and
diagnosis of diseases like breast cancer
because many patients have been
diagnosed using these panels in
long-term clinical trials clinician can
assess the risk of cancer recurrence and
survival based on information that they
provide in this chart you can see a
Meyer Kaplan curve of survival and
recurrence based on to clinical gene
panels for breast cancer
BAM 50 and Oncotype DX these panels
separate patients into three groups high
medium and low risk based on these
assessment a treatment can be selected
traditional treatments for cancer or
surgery radiotherapy and chemotherapy
each one of these treatments can have
multiple harmful side effects and is
known to be effective in only specific
situations for example tumors are
typically
irradiated before surgery or if they are
considered to be somewhat benign
chemotherapy targets cell proliferation
and often affects many other cells in
the body so not just the tumor causing
severe discomfort to patients and in
some cases leading to complicated and
even recurrence or emergence of new
cancers however since the 1990s a new
type of treatment started emerging in
clinical use called targeted cancer
therapy one such therapy is called
Herceptin or trust to zoom out this is a
monoclonal antibody that blocks the her2
receptor preventing it from receiving
the growth factor and slowing cell
growth since then immunotherapy has
transformed cancer care many of such
precision drugs are the result of
biomedical research studies of the tumor
and its micro environment mapping the
changes that characterize tumors and the
novel understanding of the biological
pathways inside tumor cells as well as
signaling pathways between tumors and
their micro environment have led to
multiple innovative interventions
blocking suppressing and enabling
existing mechanisms of action to
mitigate the effects of uncontrolled
proliferation and metastasis opdivo also
called new voloom ab is one such example
this drug was approved for medical use
in the United States in 2014 it is on
the World Health Organization's list of
essential medicines the safest and most
effective medicines needed in a health
system opdivo is a medication used to
treat a number of types of cancer
including melanoma lung cancer renal
cell carcinoma Hodgkin lymphoma head and
neck cancer colon cancer and liver
cancer but these benefits require
multiple biomarkers to guide treatment
selection and evaluate their
effectiveness
placing data analysis at the center of
such precision treatments for example
nivolumab is
used as a first line treatment for
inoperable or metastatic melanoma in
combination with another drug called
Eppley mumma another monoclonal antibody
if the cancer does not have a mutation
in the b-raf gene it is also used as a
second line treatment for inoperable or
metastatic melanoma following treatment
of epilim Ahmad and if the cancer has a
BRAF mutation if BRAF inhibitor it is
also used to treat metastatic squamous
non-small cell lung cancer with
progression in or after platinum based
drugs and for treatment of small cell
lung cancer it is also used as a second
line treatment for renal cell carcinoma
after anti-angiogenic treatment has
failed so you can see how these
treatments bringing novel precision
really require constant use of
biomarkers and very detailed
understanding of molecular processes
that happen at the sub cellular level
that's why data its analysis and
integration is at the center of modern
precision medicine researchers
biologists doctors and clinical lab
technicians are trained to understand
and utilize complicated molecular
clinical and other high-throughput
research data to diagnose disease as
well as develop use and evaluate
treatment efficacy growth in data
generation specifically when it comes to
high throughput sequencing of cancer
genomes and transcriptomes
has produced a big data problem that
precludes many cancer biologists and
oncologists from gleaning knowledge from
these data regarding the nature of
malignant processes as well as the
understanding of the relationships
between tumor genomic profiles and
treatment response in this program we
will focus on such data learning about
the various types of omics data
including data that describes
intracellular and intracellular
processes associated with disease we
will also look at the role of pathogens
and microorganism
in our bodies and the environment we
live in
to understand risks they pose to cause
acute infectious disease and chronic
risks that destabilize the immune system
and lead to cancer associated factors
and we will look at data sets that allow
us to study the relationship between
clinical and phenotypic data and
understand the molecular biology
characterized by omics data what is
often underappreciated in programs
designed around cancer is the increasing
role of viruses that we now understand
who pose a tremendous risk for cancer to
develop and complicate treatment the
epstein-barr virus formerly called human
gamma herpes virus virus 4 is one of
such viruses one of the most common
viruses in human it is best known as the
cause of infectious mononucleosis or
mana it is also associated with various
non-malignant premalignant and malignant
epstein-barr virus associated lymphomas
the virus that the virus is also
associated with the childhood disorders
of Alice and wonderland syndrome an
acute cerebral ataxia and based on some
evidence higher risk of developing
certain autoimmune diseases such as
lupus rheumatoid arthritis and multiple
sclerosis chlorosis about 200,000 cancer
cases per year are thought to be
attributable to EBV another prevalent
DNA virus is human papilloma virus from
the papilloma Verde family approximately
5% of all new cancers diagnosed in 2002
were attributable to HPV another such
pathogen is hepatitis B and C the most
common risk factor for liver cancer
about 60% of liver cancer diagnosis are
due to causes chronic and hepatitis B
leading to over 700,000 deaths from
liver cancer annually so that's why this
bioinformatics for precision medicine is
a program designed to
reduce the topics of basic and
translational oncology to study next
generation sequencing understanding DNA
variants and the mutations that we can
detect in DNA we will talk about
next-generation sequencing for
transcriptomics where we can analyze
gene expression patterns and see the
difference in gene expression between
multiple conditions and also appreciate
the role of machine learning in analysis
of arnie seek data we'll talk about
different types of projects looking at
different resources and public databases
we'll talk about genomics in viral adji
and how we can study viral genomes
inside the human cells and in other
hosts we'll talk about the process of
multiple sequence alignment and
evolutionary studies for viruses and
we'll be able to go in-depth and discuss
different pipeline results the
annotation of those results and
biological interpretation we'll also
talk about some of the challenges that
make infectious diseases such an
increasing risk and how they are related
to cancer and finally we will talk about
the basic biology of host pathogen
interaction that is important to
understand as you look at these causes
of major chronic diseases but before we
go on I wanted to give you an overview
of some of the resources that we've
prepared in this program and guide you
to the various links where you can see
some of those and start interacting with
the program resources the primary
location for all of these resources
together is going to be on this
educational portal edu T - bio info on
this portal you will see an
organizational page where we have a home
page that describes the process of the
different sessions and how they are
organized in the program gives you
access to the forum where we will post
recordings of these
and interact with you to discuss
different topics and challenges that
you're facing you will have a list of
courses that you can see here in the
back that are going to be provided for
all of the participants of the program
some project examples that we will
review where we will utilize data sets
from publicly from published journals
you will see progress and keep track of
where you are related to your peers on
the program and see other elements of
the program that will help you make the
most out of this bioinformatics for
precision medicine program so let's take
a look once you have registered you
should have received an email on how to
access this link in this link you will
see a number of different resources for
example right here you will see the
upcoming events today we will talk about
introduction to translational oncology
research you can also navigate to future
events and see what's coming up down
here you will see activity from
participants of the program for example
beeps I recently posted a topic welcome
to the forum and session recordings
those are going to be available right
here on the forum tab so on the forum
tab you will see in recordings of the
sessions you'll see highlighted profiles
of people that have joined the program
and you'll see some of the topics and
datasets that we will be utilizing in
different sessions right here you'll
find the courses so online sessions are
going to be intermixed with some of the
courses that you can take at your own
pace a synchronously so you'll be able
to complete these courses and benefit
from some of those basic things so that
the sessions that we have are more
interactive and you can spend the time
during the sessions practicing some of
the skills that you've learned and
explore different data sets and projects
that we've prepared for the program so
as you go through the courses you'll
start seeing your progress and you'll be
able to complete those and get an
individual certificate of
completion for each one of these courses
some of the courses will have just the
radical background and some of them will
have some practical assignments that you
can complete there are also going to be
some projects that we will keep adding
throughout the program so that those of
you that have completed some of the
projects some of the courses can also
try to apply the learning skills on some
of these projects datasets here we will
also measure the progress we'll look at
how all of the participants of the
program are making their way through the
course material practicing some of the
pipeline's that we will be discussing in
the sessions and we will see how we can
all achieve a higher level of
interactive discussions so that we can
start working on independent projects so
the basic idea is that we will keep
track of your activity you'll be able to
see track of your activity and we'll try
to address any types of issues that come
up as a result of this interaction so if
you have not done so yet you can also
join this program today by completing
your registration and start filling out
your profile so for all of the members
that have joined I do want to ask that
you actually go through your profile
make sure that you have a full name have
some kind of a profile image or an
avatar and that way that information
will be used in the program certificate
as well as the individual certificates
of courses that you will receive after
completing the assignments and the
quizzes including in that course
another resource is the tip bio info
platform the t-value info platform is
really a springboard for you to launch
your experience in bioinformatics it
offers a variety of resources that
include some cloud-based tools that you
can use to process large datasets it
gives you some guidance on how these
tools work together by organizing them
into logical pipelines where each step
of the way is explained with a detailed
explanation of that method as well as
some links to where you can find the
algorithms and potentially even the
source code for some of the open source
methods and will also utilize some
additional tools those additional tools
will help you improve your ability to
visualize data interact with this data
and get some biological interpretation
of the analysis results before I
continue let's see if there's any
questions so I'm just going to pull up
in the chat for those of you that have
not yet received your login information
we will still be emailing you the access
for the T bio info platform and make
sure that you understand that the
difference between the educational
portal and the practical portal is going
to be based on a specific password
emailed to your email so if you could
make sure that you add marketing at Pine
dot bio to your contact list that will
help you receive any kind of information
that will be needed for the program
you
okay so if you have any questions you
can type them right here in chat or you
can email us later and even post your
questions on the forum as I mentioned
the forum is the best place for you to
post any kinds of technical issues or
any kinds of questions that you might
have so let's go on to today's topic
bioinformatics and translational
oncology research so we'll talk briefly
about cancer biology looking at changes
in organs tissues and cells and thinking
about some of the molecular factors in
tumor development and metastasis
clinical and molecular data and oncology
studies and how we can analyze phenotype
genotype relationships ok briefly I'll
answer the question that came up from MC
so in the platform is ace is this
expesive fide the pathway and also
explained each step and which algorithms
can be used I will do a brief
demonstration for those of you that have
not had a chance to use the platform so
this is the T violin for platform you
can go on this link server that T - bio
info it's a cloud-based platform that
includes many different tools for
analysis of next-generation sequencing
data mass spectroscopy data structural
biology data and provide some tools for
data integration and modeling you'll
find that each section is organized by
the data type and has a number of tools
that you can use to process integrate
and annotate some of the data we have a
set of demo pipelines that I'll show you
they don't include the steps for
uploading the data but you'll get a
sense of what the platform includes so
here's the demo for RNA seek you'll find
here that each step of the way explains
the logic behind what we are trying to
do so as we start the pipeline it will
explain RNA seek how we will pre process
map
and quantify levels of gene expression
you'll then see some options highlighted
to limit based on what you are going to
do in this pipeline for example we can
use some pre-processing steps to
eliminate some of the annotation some of
the technical variation you can read
about what this step does you can also
then connect this to mapping for example
when we map using high sat you can read
about high sad - and go to the article
that describes what high sat - does then
we need to construct isoforms and update
the GTF file and then we can map the
reads to quantify the expression levels
and prepare a table of expression so the
table of expression will look like this
and actually by completing this pipeline
you will receive the downloads that a
typical pipeline like that will produce
so by leveraging the platform this is an
example of an educational use we can
just go through the steps and explain
them see the inputs and the outputs
understand the role of each algorithm in
a pipeline but in the program itself
will actually use the live version of
the platform for those that have
completed their registration you will be
able to use this on specific curated
data sets that we've prepared for this
program but you'll also be able to apply
this data apply this platform or this
analysis that you've practiced on two
new types of data sets that you prepare
as your own independent projects towards
the end of the program so the objective
of the program will be to provide you
with some basic tools like these that
you can quickly launch your analysis and
once you've launched your analysis you
can take it as far as you want to with
the tools that we provide or with some
of the other tools that we will cover as
well as some of the open source tools
like our studio and others okay so
hopefully MC that answers your
yes I will happily explain about
projects but let me go first through the
topic of today's session because the
projects will start making a lot more
sense after we review some of the basic
concepts that we are going to introduce
in today's session so bioinformatics and
translational oncology research let's
talk briefly about the molecular
components the biology of cancer and
then we'll talk about some of the data
types that allow us to study this
biology at the tumor and the tumor
microenvironment levels so what happens
to a cell to make it become cancers 30
years ago scientists could not offer a
coherent answer to this question they
knew that cancer arose from cells that
began to proliferate uncontrollably
within the body and they knew that
chemicals radiation and viruses could
trigger this change but exactly how it
happened was a mystery research across
the last three decades however has
revolutionized our understanding of kids
in large part the success was made
possible by the development and
application of the techniques of
molecular biology techniques that
enabled researchers to probe and
describe features of individual cells in
ways unimaginable a century ago today we
know that cancer is a disease of
molecules and genes and we even know
many of the molecules and genes involved
in fact our increasing understanding of
these genes is making possible the
development of exciting new strategies
for avoiding forestalling and even
correcting the changes that lead to
cancer cancer cells differ from normal
cells in many ways that allow them to
grow out of control and become invasive
to other tissues one important
difference is that cancer cells are less
specialized than normal cells that is
whereas normal cells mature into very
distinct cells cell types with specific
functions cancer cells do not this is
one reason that unlike normal cells
cancer cells continue to do
without stopping cancer solos have large
variably shaped nuclei they're composed
of many dividing cells with disorganized
arrangement cells are variable sizes and
shape and overall display a loss of
normal features so you can see here a
comparison of normal and cancer cells
what we're looking at is called
phenotype so we can describe the
different shape patterns and different
properties or characteristics of cells
and tissues to make a distinction from
what we know of normal cells in addition
cancer cells are able to ignore signals
that normally sells pass to each other
to stop dividing or that beginning
process is known as programmed cell
death or apoptosis which the body uses
to get rid of a needed cells cancer
cells may be able to influence normal
cells molecules and blood vessels that
surround and seeded tumor an area known
as the micro environment for instance
cancer cells can induce nearby normal
cells to form blood vessels that supply
tumors with oxygen and nutrients which
they need to grow these blood vessels
also remove waste product from tumors so
the cell itself changes but also starts
changing the environment around it and
as the tumor grows it actually sucks out
a lot of the resources needed for normal
cells around around the tumor the micro
environment actually includes multiple
cells including the immune cells and
cancer cells are also often able to
evade the immune system a network of
organs tissues and specialized cells
that protects the body from infection
and other conditions
although the immune system normally
removes damaged or abnormal cells from
the body some cancer cells are able to
hide from the immune system and evaded
from being detected tumors can also use
the immune system to
they live and grow for example with the
help of certain immune system cells that
normally prevent a runaway immune
escaped response cancer cells can
actually keep the immune system from
killing cancer cells and so we can
differentiate between hot and cold
tumors tumors described as hot are those
that show signs of inflammation meaning
the tumor has already been infiltrated
by t-cells rushing to fight the
cancerous cells the tumor cells have
undergone many mutations and create new
antigens recognized by these t-cells the
main idea behind checkpoint inhibition
for example is to use antibodies to
mobilize the t-cell response during the
attack on the tumor and t-cells become
exhausted and lose important functions
needed to kill tumor cells the
exhaustion is brought on by constant
exposure to tumor antigens and signaling
to checkpoint receptors the antibodies
block signaling through these receptors
to prevent this loss of function so what
are called tumors call in contrast non
immunogenic called tumors have not yet
been infiltrated with t-cells a sign
that the immune response is not working
for one reason or another the lack of
t-cells makes it difficult to provoke an
immune response with immunotherapy drugs
these types of tumors are mostly treated
with traditional cancer therapies most
breast cancers ovarian cancer prostate
cancer pancreatic cancer and
glioblastoma are typically cold tumors
which poses a problem for the widespread
use of immunotherapies the micro
environment surrounding cold tumors
contains myeloid divide derived
suppressor cells and T regulatory cells
which are known to dampen the immune
response and inhibit T cells trying to
move into the tumor so the tumor grows
we recruit cells around it to form a
specific type of a micro environment and
that micro environment actually can help
us understand what types of mechanisms
are being activated and how we can
target the tumor growth that is
the main reason that cancer is so
serious is its ability to spread in the
body throughout many different tissues
cancer cells can spread locally by
moving into nearby normal tissue and
they can also spread regionally to
nearby lymph nodes tissues and organs
and it can spread to distant parts of
the body when this happens it is called
metastatic cancer for many types of
cancer it is also called stage 4 cancer
the process by which cancer cells spread
to other parts of the body is called
metastasis when observed under a
microscope and tested in other ways
minta static cancer cells have features
like that of the ordinary primary cancer
and not like the cells in the place
where the cancer is found this is how
doctors can tell that it is a cancer
that has spread from another part of the
body metastatic cancer has the same name
as the primary cancer for example breast
cancer that spreads to lung cancer is
called metastatic breast cancer not lung
cancer it is treated as stage 4 breast
cancer not as lung cancer so to remember
these aspects of cancer biology hallmark
features of cancer were identified these
are distinctive and complementary
capabilities that enable tumor growth
and metastatic dissemination these have
evolved over the past decade and now
include original six which is sustaining
proliferative signaling evading growth
suppressors activation invasion and
metastasis enabling replicative
immortality reducing NGO Genesis
energetics and resisting cell deaths an
additional four have been added
deregulation cellular energetics
avoiding immune destruction tumor
promoting inflammation genome
instability and mutation so during this
program we'll talk about these hallmark
features of cancer and how they can be
studied using specific types of data for
example we have to understand each cell
to understand what type of cell is found
in a specific tumor or the place where
it is metastasizing - so bioinformatics
is a key aspect of characterizing the
different cell types and tissues as well
as being able to understand what might
be the reason for these cells to
differentiate into cancer cells or even
start traveling throughout the body and
causing metastasis throughout different
tissues when we speak about
bioinformatics we're going to primarily
speak not about the biology first but
we're first going to focus on the data
we'll talk about changes in the DNA
where we can identify specific genes and
positions on the DNA and in the
chromosomes and then study mRNA
transcriptions or how that specific gene
is translated into a functional mRNA and
eventually a protein as a result we'll
learn how to understand the processes
that happen at the subcellular level and
study specific data types and integrate
them together to understand how this
biology is reflected in the data when we
talk about translational oncology
research a lot of that type of research
utilizes next-generation sequencing so
in our next session we'll talk about the
process of next-generation sequencing
and we'll see some examples of how this
type of data could be processed when we
talk about the basic and translational
oncology research we'll talk about how
these kinds of studies at different
levels can inform anything from the
basic understanding of the mechanisms
behind cancer growth and metastasis all
the way to actual selection of treatment
and so we'll talk about different
projects that will look at patient
derived cell lines then patient-derived
xenograft models animal models that have
tumors from people engraved into their
bodies so that we can study the role of
the micro environment around them and
we'll talk about data from real
patience where clinical trials of
specific types of disease or specific
treatments can help generate a
collection of data that can helps us
understand how these basic processes
that we can study in individual cells
actually work in the human population so
how is this used by a doctor how is it
relevant for a clinician a doctor can
detect cancer once clinical signs are
evident from available data patient
scans x-rays or blood tests once
detected a tumor is evaluated for
malignancy criteria for malignancy
include increased cell proliferation
loss of differentiation infiltrative
growth and metastasis and metastasis to
other organs in other words we have to
identify these hallmark features of
cancer if the tumor that has formed from
these cells is still contained within
tissue of origin it is called in situ
cancer in situ cancer may remain
contained indefinitely if some cells
experience additional mutations that
allow the tumor to invade neighboring
tissues and shed cells in the blood or
lymph the tumor is said to be malignant
the escaped cells may establish new
tumors metastasis at other locations of
the body the development of cancer cells
is a process of deregulation of key
molecular mechanisms so monitoring those
mechanisms along the way and seeing the
impact of treatment on those mechanisms
helps the doctor change the mode of
treatment and identify potential new
targets for a treatment to stop what's
going on a big part of that is what's
called data mining so data mining allows
us to find patterns in data and then use
those patterns for Biological
interpretation but low throughput data
like blood count white blood count heart
rate or even basic things like weight
and size are simple to analyze we can
simply plot them visually and we'll find
some patterns just like you see right
here so when we have low
throughput data for example phenotypic
data that data helps describe what we
see and provide us with a quick way to
distinguish between certain conditions
for example here you can see how size
and weight can easily differentiate
between men and women but when we come
to high-throughput data and this data
has complex relationships that it
describes it really becomes difficult to
just simply look at the data and
understand what it means so we'll talk
about some of the methods of data mining
and machine learning that can help us
associate various profiles of individual
genes positions on the DNA and they're
made mutability to differentiate between
these different conditions but this
basic mechanistic understanding of
what's going on is even more complex
when we talk about real patients so
we'll also talk about such studies as
the Cancer Genome Atlas that allow us to
take patient data and look at how real
patients in different clinical trials
grouped by different types of cancers
and different types of free other
conditions can be studied to understand
the need for integration of various
molecular data types and Association of
those molecular data types with clinical
phenotypes with what is actually known
about the phenotype of those patients so
now let's talk about some of the
projects that will prepare I'll just
give you a couple of examples one
example is a project called modeling
precision treatment of breast cancer
this project which was featured in
genome biology in 2013 is interesting
because the authors assembled a dataset
of about 50 different breast cancer cell
lines that represent the whole spectrum
of breast cancer variations the cell
lines have genomics transcriptomics and
proteomics data as well as an advocacy
measurement of commonly used and
experimental cancer drugs that include
chemotherapy and different
targeted treatments this is a project
that really helps understand how modern
use of machine learning and Big Data can
inform treatment selection in
combination with high to put molecular
data data that can characterize
different conditions at their sub
cellular level we'll also talk about
some of the clinical data that is
available in projects like the TCGA
liver cancer is an example where we will
take a look at the different risk
factors for example you can see here
different types of risk factors
associated with different hepatocellular
carcinoma patients and one of the
factors like we said is hepatitis C and
B that is prevalent in Asia and Africa
so we'll look at how clinical data that
records ethnicity as well as viral
hepatitis
serology helps understand the risk and
the causative agents behind liver cancer
so we'll actually take the publication
that is called comprehensive and
integrative genomic characterization of
hepatocellular carcinoma and we'll take
at the data sets that they provide
including exome sequencing copy number
variation mrna seek micro RNAs and other
data to help us understand the molecular
profiles of hepatocellular carcinoma and
the role of pathogens like hepatitis C
and B in developing this kind of
condition do you have any questions
about what we just reviewed and Supra
does that make sense about the projects
or did you have any additional questions
about the projects
okay excellent so does anyone else have
any questions
please again post them in the chat and
what I would like to do next is review
the program schedule and talk a little
bit more in detail about future sessions
that we will have
okay if there's no questions for now
I'll continue so in our next session
we'll start talking about
next-generation sequencing and how we
can use NGS the data to analyze DNA
variation
okay there's a question what is a good
way to retrieve papers with a sequence
data excellent question
well actually talk about the process of
finding a good data set and evaluating
the data set that can answer a specific
question so before you jump to looking
for a specific data set it's important
to develop the project idea to a level
where you can already plan the analysis
steps and anticipate the kinds of
results of analysis you will find so
that you can look for the appropriate
data to answer your question so I think
what we'll try to do is we'll learn
about the different types of data will
then look at a few different examples
and we'll see how that data is utilized
at a number of different examples and
then we will actually show you how to
access some of these repositories and
how to navigate for example NCBI one of
the largest collections of biotechnology
information to find sequencing data of
different types produced by different
mechanisms and representing different
types of experimental designs
um and then the question this session
will be posted on the forum yes so
definitely the recordings of the session
after we are done with the session the
recording will be posted on the forum
and on our YouTube channel
privately in the future sessions and
this session which is the first session
about the program will be posted for
everyone to see so you will be welcome
to see that as well
so in our next session we'll talk about
the different types of next-generation
sequencing in the session after that we
will start talking about processing next
generation sequencing data and the
different steps that play a role in our
ability to interpret the results of that
processing and we'll also talk about
specifically gene expression or RNA seek
studies okay another question here can
fatty liver stage develop into a liver
cancer yes we'll talk about different
factors contributing to liver cancer
including how the process it doesn't
happen overnight right so there are
stages and some stages could be
reversible and then there are different
genetic or pathogen related or even
environmental factors leading to
different types of cancer so we'll talk
about that in one of the sessions after
we study DNA variation and gene
expression profiles we'll start talking
about machine learning for gene
expression data when we come to big data
sets for each sample we have thousands
of genes that could be characterized one
of the challenges is to find meaningful
patterns associated with a specific
phenotype and so machine learning has
the ability to help us to mine and
explore the different patterns and use
classification and feature selection to
identify the links between the phenotype
and very specific patterns that we've
identified in genes or combinations of
genes we'll then to answer your question
talk about different data sources to be
able to find data to study oncology and
we'll talk about different types of
data that is available for example we'll
talk about SRA or sequence read archive
datasets where you can find raw read
data so you can find fast queue files
and SRA files and those will be used to
to first process and map all the
different types of variation as you know
variation is based on the type of
analysis that you do to that data and
the way that the data was prepared so
we'll talk about those different factors
well also talk about a repository called
gene expression omnibus or geo that data
set or that database contains a lot of
different process datasets so data sets
that already have gene expression tables
but it's also important to understand
how those tables were prepared not all
tables are going to be used for
different types of downstream analyses
for example for differential gene
expression you'd have to find a specific
type of data and potentially even pre
process it using different normalization
techniques so we'll talk about those as
well and then we'll talk about such data
sets like the Cancer Genome Atlas that
as I mentioned contains multiple types
of omics per individual sample including
for example blood as a control sample
for each patient which helps us
eliminate the germline mutations and
focus on somatic mutations associated
with cancers we'll also talk about a
database called cosmic which is a
database that accumulates annotation of
different mutations in specific genes
associated with conditions and treatment
response so after that we'll talk about
viral genomes in the host transcriptome
so we'll talk about the detection of
different viruses these could be viruses
that cause cancer these could be viruses
that cause inflammation and they could
be just the cause of infectious diseases
but we'll talk about how are those
detected and so when we talk about
finding a viral genome we
actually mean finding specific reads
that give significant indication for
each for either a whole genome or
specific proteins of that virus and some
of the challenges associated with
preparing the right kind of data to be
able to detect those when we take
samples from patients or from other
hosts will then talk about analysis that
helps us characterize those different
genomes a lot of times genomes of
viruses mutate much faster than larger
genomes from hosts like humans and so
we'll talk about evolutionary studies
and phylogenetic analysis and we'll talk
about how we can map the differences in
the genomic sequence to understand
relationships between viruses that have
been studied and are known and novel
ones that potentially might be found in
a specific patient or a group of
patients and then we'll do an in-depth
discussion of different types of
workflows and pipelines that are
possible to study different aspects of
genomic variation and we'll talk about
how do we extract the most information
to talk about the biological
significance of the analysis results so
we'll actually talk about how we can use
this type of analysis to draw a
biological conclusions and we'll talk
about some of the details of the outputs
so that we can make reliable and solid
interpretation of those results will
also talk about pandemics a big part of
what we observe in the current pandemic
is that people with pre-existing
conditions are affected in a much more
significant way than healthy people and
so death rates and mortality rates in an
infectious outbreak like this actually
highlight some of the challenges that
people with pre-existing conditions
including cancer including autoimmune
diseases might have and so we'll look at
how this example of this novel
coronavirus
pandemic actually highlights some of the
previous topics that we've discussed
before that
associated with these chronic conditions
and to understand the biology of
host-pathogen interaction we'll look at
different types of considerations some
of these pathogens that we've already
described have specific treatments there
are some resistance elements for those
pathogens to evade those treatments
we'll talk about those we'll also talk
about the process of vaccine design for
example human papilloma virus already
has a vaccine so we'll talk about herpes
virus and and other types of viruses
that have been the subject of vaccine
design discussions for many years and
what are some of the challenges and
opportunities in that space so to
continue with this program again I
invite all of you that have already
registered to go and start the process
of exploring the different resources
associated with this program this
program will have sessions that we just
described and for each session there's
going to be an Associated resource so
for today's session the associated
resource is introduction to
bioinformatics perhaps many of you
already know enough about bioinformatics
not to complete the introduction to
bioinformatics course but I do want to
encourage you to do that because one of
the first things that we want to achieve
from that specific course is to learn
about you we don't have time to interact
with each one of you one on one but the
first step of this course is to fill out
a form about you and we would love to
learn about where you came from what is
your level of education what about
precision medicine interests you and
what kinds of objectives do you have for
this course or for this program so
please make sure that even for the sake
of going through that process of letting
us know more about you please complete
this bioinformatics or introduction to
bioinformatics course it does highlight
some of the big biomedical data
challenges and opportunities that are
challenging research and healthcare as
we
and so a great example one of the people
that has already joined the program did
an excellent job at completing the
profile so I didn't let him know before
the session but we did want to highlight
a but tabi is a clinical laboratory and
biomedical scientist at ACP HS I don't
not sure what that stands for but I'll
be looking forward to finding out and
former NHL Oh in bio defence and
emerging infectious diseases and he is
an instructor so I do want to encourage
all of you to complete your profile as
much as possible and also explore some
of the and there he added in the chats
Albin in colleges of Albany and Health
Sciences ok great thank you for letting
us know and I do encourage all of you to
try and complete your profile as much as
possible we do have a number of
resources to connect and we feel like
this program is not only a way to learn
about these topics and practice the
analysis eventually as you'll discover
in any research project a research
project is a collaboration between a
team of people from many different
backgrounds so hopefully we can help put
together teams of collaborators with
different types of backgrounds and
different levels of experience to help
contribute to an effective project okay
in the correction here it's Alberni
College of Pharmacy and health sciences
in New York in the USA alright great and
ever we are happy to have you here and
all of you as well they're joining this
program so let me briefly describe some
of the other resources that you will
find let's go to the educational place
here so as I mentioned here you will
find your profile some of your other
profiles also I don't want to go over
anybody else's we do have some of the
participants of our previous programs
here and so we're excited to have you
here as well Sara
has been with us in several programs
from Florida Cassidy Barnes and others I
recognize as well so a lot of the people
participating in these programs I
imagine have an interest in continuing
to develop your skills and applying
those skills to new projects and really
looking at how those projects could be
more comprehensive more impactful more
significant so we will bring in a number
of experts in bioinformatics to help
address those projects and that will
happen towards the end of the program ok
so I do want to point to the link about
the syllabus the syllabus is going to
include kind of a timeline of all the
different sessions that we just
described and I encourage all of you to
go through this timeline and see some of
the associated courses and we will
continue to do add more information on
here so if you have any info any
questions about this syllabus you can
reach out to us and we'll go through the
syllabus again next time to make sure
that everything is clear oh sorry that
was a private message okay
what are these different courses the
courses are going to include different
basic skills the courses will have an
overview and then you'll be able to see
the curriculum inside the course after
you complete the course you'll be able
to get a certificate for finishing that
course and as you go through the course
you'll see the course results here
increased so one of the things that
we've noticed is that a lot of people
actually do not have and don't see the
finished course button so if you've
started some of these courses or you
will start some of these courses make
sure that you complete all of their
assignments and you finish at the end at
complete course you also see
that each course has a number of
different elements there for example
inside a course you will have a control
section on the top so we know that some
of you might see offline time that you
might want to take these resources with
you so you'll be able to use some of
these control points here on top so what
are those first of all you'll see that
your profile is going to come with
associated points I'll talk about points
here in a second and you can get
notifications so those notifications
will help you see specific elements of
interaction with other people on the
platform or your own activity to keep
track of what's going on the course will
include a course outline ability to
search for specific course topics
navigating between the different
sections of the course you can magnify
any of the images that seem too small or
unclear you can magnify them you can
download the PDF of that lesson and take
them with you and also for those of you
that struggle with small size font you
can increase the font size and of course
close the lesson if you want to go back
to the main menu we also have online
materials that you can use to study this
offline and you will see specific
materials like specific words
highlighted and explained when you hover
over that word if you see it underlined
you can see the different specific terms
that might be important to understand
clearly some of the courses have just
basic material with quizzes others have
assignments and those are hands-on
assignments that are actually reviewed
by us you'll see that this assignment
for example will ask you to run a
pipeline and sometimes you will have the
ability to do it interactively on the
platform and then at the end submit your
assignment results
so those assignment results will be
by us typically in between different
sessions if you have any questions about
those assignments you're always welcome
to publish your questions either within
the assignment or on the forum and we've
received multiple feedback points from
previous participants of our programs
and courses for example Ricardo here
from Peru says that this course was
spectacular I feel that I learned a lot
about transcriptomics from its
definition studying to learning how to
apply algorithms in a simplify and easy
way on the platform so really I wanted
to highlight here that these courses are
appropriate for any level we had people
from high schools that took the time to
review these courses and gave us
positive feedback as well as faculty
that really enjoyed taking some of the
combination of practical and theoretical
knowledge that these courses provide so
what are some of the course topics that
are included in these courses we'll talk
about a whole series of topics in RNA
seek on transcriptomic data analysis
including transcriptomics one two three
and four where it's where the processing
of data the types of sequencing data the
basic result of the table of expression
is explained then in transcriptomics
tomb we talked about statistical
analysis analysis of different
expression levels differential gene
expression and some additional factor
regression analysis that utilizes
regression to identify relationships
between experimental design and gene
expression levels transcriptomics 3 that
talks about Big Data data mining and
machine learning and transcriptomics 4
that talks about single-cell
transcriptomics we also have a series of
courses on next-generation sequencing
genomic data like whole genome
sequencing and whole exome sequencing
where you will learn about the very
basics like introduction to genomics
will teach you about different types of
mutations and variations found in the
DNA and then genomics 1 and 2 we'll talk
about C
nucleotide mutations or polymorphisms in
somatic and germline as well as copy
number variation and the statistical
analysis of accumulation of mutations in
different regions we will also talk
about the microbiome and the viral and
so an important resource to understand
the different sequencing techniques and
ability to study individual viruses as
well as communities of microbiome
composition will be explained in
metagenomics 1 and 2 so in our next
session we will start talking about
next-generation sequencing how do we
start analyzing DNA variation so again
the objective before now and then is to
try and complete introduction to
bioinformatics and online course and in
synchronous course and next time we meet
we'll talk about the specifics of
processing analysis and interpretation
of DNA variants found in next-generation
sequencing data do you have any
questions I'll be happy to answer any
questions that you might have now
you
you
okay so you can take your time to add
your questions to the chat the objective
of this program is to combine the
theoretical and practical materials that
we have on the platform to actually get
a hands-on experience to process some of
this data get certificates of completion
or in our next session in the beginning
we'll talk about certificates of
excellence where you can actually stand
out from the rest by working on an
independent project if you choose to do
so and get some assistance from us on
how to do that to get started we'll
provide you with some examples of
projects that you can go through and
understand how the data was analyzed
where the data came from access the same
data and then try to innovate there or
apply the same skills that you learn in
those projects to a completely new data
set that will actually help you to find
as I see that there's no questions I
think that's all we have for today
I'm really excited about starting this
program together with you I'll be
looking forward to getting to know you
by looking at your profiles and hope
that you can complete as many elements
in those profit profiles as possible
we do have a LinkedIn group that you're
welcome to join where we go through some
of the job opportunities research
opportunities projects and different
topics that are important to precision
medicine and machine learning as to make
sure that be fair maybe you could post a
link to our LinkedIn group as well as a
Facebook group and then for all of you
joined and we'll look forward to seeing
you again in our next session